por qué
[Música]
el próximo 2 de octubre los brasileños
están convocados a las urnas para unas
elecciones generales marcadas por la
polarización el agotamiento ciudadano y
también muchos temas políticos sobre la
mesa los brasileños van a elegir a su
nuevo presidente vicepresidente 27 de
los 81 escaños del senado federal y 513
escaños de la cámara de diputados así
como los 27 gobernadores estatales y mil
59 diputados locales esta elección es
conocida también como el superdomingo
haremos entonces énfasis en las
elecciones presidenciales hay 11
candidatos que intentarán llegar a la
silla presidencial en sus pantallas
pueden ver los nombres de todos ellos y
de estas 11 candidaturas hay que decir
que solamente 4 pertenecen a
candidaturas de mujeres
pasemos entonces a ver los dos
candidatos que están liderando hasta
ahora la intención de voto de los
ciudadanos
estamos hablando de luiz inácio lula da
silva ex sindicalista también es
candidato por el partido de los
trabajadores ya fue presidente de brasil
en dos periodos consecutivos entre el
año 2003 y el 2010 lula aspira a un
tercer mandato presidencial y también
está liderando y repuntando en las
encuestas el actual presidente ayer
bolsonaro del partido liberal que ha
estado en el cargo desde el 2019 y
aspira a ser elegido para gobernar por
un segundo mandato consecutivo
en una esta es una elección crucial para
todo el país para todo brasil es una
elección que ha sido ya catalogada por
muchos analistas como una elección de
alto voltaje porque tiene como
característica la polarización como lo
estaba diciendo
esto ha hecho que quede en evidencia que
los dos candidatos que les estábamos
mostrando que lideran las encuestas de
los ciudadanos no podrían representar
dos orillas' políticas más diferentes
por un lado esta bolsonaro que es
actualmente el presidente que es
calificado de populista de nacionalista
y que tiene una agenda que es respaldada
por sectores muy conservadores y también
por sectores religiosos
principalmente los cristianos en la otra
orilla está el expresidente lula da
silva ex líder sindical como ya les
decía que estuvo incluso encarcelado por
corrupción hasta que fueron anulados
todas las condenas en su contra lo
cierto es que esta será una campaña con
propuestas de visiones muy diferentes en
cuanto a la visión que hay que tener de
brasil pero con un punto en común
levantar la economía después de la
pandemia de kobe 19 seguir haciendo
frente anda que continua ya hemos hecho
apertura a nivel económico y social en
la mayoría de países alrededor del mundo
pero todavía la pandemia continúa
también hacer frente a las adversidades
que se están presentando en el escenario
internacional en la actualidad la guerra
en ucrania las discrepancias entre
estados unidos china la unión europea y
rusia- etcétera y también luchar contra
los problemas locales que tiene brasil
que todos conocemos la pobreza la
inseguridad la falta de infraestructura
que son tal vez temas transversales para
la gran mayoría de los países en nuestro
continente principalmente en suramérica
por eso hoy en el debate de france 24
luz verde para la carrera para llegar al
palacio de planalto y ese es nuestro
tema de análisis hoy en el debate de
france 24 para conversar sobre este tema
hemos invitado a johana amaya ella es
politóloga e internacionalista es
profesora de la universidad king's
college en la ciudad de londres y
también de la universidad o university
college london también está con nosotros
wagner iglesias él es sociólogo y
profesor de la universidad de sao paulo
en brasil les recuerdo que también
ustedes hacen parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar sus preguntas y comentarios
a través de las redes sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram y en
facebook en donde no se encuentran como
france24 bajo ese arroba santi logo que
es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta para
que dejen todos sus comentarios numeral
el debate efe 24 también importante en
youtube pueden seguir nuestra señal en
streaming pueden dejar los comentarios
en el chat en vivo y aprovecho para
saludar a las personas que nos están
escuchando a través del podcast todos
los contenidos de este programa no se
encuentran ya están disponibles en
plataformas como app el podcast spotify
deezer y tuning
comienza entonces saludando a johanna
que se encuentra en el reino unido-
giovanna gracias por estar con nosotros
en el programa punto de partida para
conocer posiciones de los invitados del
programa y el panorama general desde su
punto de vista a johanna cómo llega a
brasil a estas elecciones presidenciales
elecciones generales porque varios
cargos pero nos enfocamos en las
presidenciales
santiago buenas tardes en bogotá buenas
noches en el reino unido gracias por
invitarme a un panorama general es
difícil de resumir pero diría que en
este momento aunque hay un momento de
estabilización macroeconómica
después de la pandemia que está jugando
a favor de bolsonaro en términos
generales tenemos una economía devastada
con una inflación bastante alta la más
alta desde 1996 y desde la
implementación del plan real en los
noventas es el primer presidente que
sale dejando el salario mínimo mucho
menor de lo que inició cuando inició su
periodo presidencial
esto en términos económicos en términos
ambientales hay una devastación de la
amazonía y este es un tema que no sólo
concierne a brasil sino a la humanidad
por esto estas elecciones no son menores
es la segunda democracia más grande del
hemisferio occidental con 148 mil
electores
es además una de las grandes reservas
ambientales por esto estas elecciones
son importantes porque el desempeño en
la política económica y ambiental que ha
tenido bolsonaro está afectando no sólo
a brasil sino a las dinámicas del cambio
climático mundial paso ahora a darle la
bienvenida a wagner en la ciudad de sao
pablo wagner se lleva viendo el programa
y punto de partida también la misma
pregunta su panorama de cómo está brasil
de cara a estas elecciones
presidenciales del 2 de octubre cuál es
su análisis
hola santiago me gusta estar aquí con
usted hoy con un saludo también a juana
y a todas las personas que nos acompañan
en las distintas plataformas
de elección de mucha polarización esta
vez de ahí estoy de acuerdo con jugada
estamos en un momento de aunque hay
alguna estabilidad económica y brasil
hoy está devastado no solamente por la
las consecuencias económicas de la
pandemia sino también por la propia
política económica del gobierno
de jair bolsonaro
tenemos más de 10 por ciento de
desempleo formal en brasil y mucho más
gente millones de personas que están en
la informalidad y pulula representa la
posibilidad de regreso a una situación
de más o menos una década atrás cuando
brasil intentaba consolidar un estado
socialdemócrata con inclusión con
combate al hambre con combate a la
pobreza y la desigualdad
sin embargo lula aunque hoy esté
liderando en el liderazgo de las
encuestas en los últimos días las
encuestas más recientes
apuntan para una recuperación aunque un
poco lenta pero la recuperación de las
intenciones de voto por parte del actual
presidente a el bolsón ar entonces creo
que para las próximas semanas vamos a
tener una profundización de esta
polarización incluso porque mañana
empieza la campaña en los medios de
comunicación radio televisión y todo más
las plataformas distintas de internet y
creo yo que el clima se va a calentar
mucho más en los próximos días claro hoy
vamos a analizar justo porque es el
punto de partida pero esto conforme se
vaya acercando a la fecha de las
elecciones va a estar mucho más
interesante lo que vayan diciendo
también los candidatos en sus diferentes
mitin en sus propuestas y cómo van a ir
subiendo y bajando los candidatos esto
es solamente el punto de partida de
estas elecciones vamos a hacer un
barrido general continuó con wagner en
la ciudad de sao paulo para hacer la
ronda a la inversa y quiero que
comencemos hablando por él justamente el
presidente jair bolsonaro como llega a
él como presidente candidato a esta
elección viene arrastrando las
dificultades que usted mencionaba que
está presentando el país en esa
recuperación económica tras la pandemia
de las dificultades que hay a nivel
social pero sin embargo sigue teniendo
aceptación de algunos sectores de la
sociedad pese a que su popularidad ha
bajado a lo largo del mandato como es el
panorama que usted y el análisis que
usted hace del presidente candidato si
este escenario
totalmente verdadero bolsonaro bajó un
poco su popularidad a lo largo de los
últimos años sin embargo mantiene el
apoyo de una parte de una parcela
significativa de la población brasileña
más o menos 35 por ciento más o menos
ahí y tal vez llegue en las próximas
encuestas a 40 por ciento de las
intenciones de voto
hay mucho hay mucho desgaste en la
imagen de evolucionar no solo con
relación a la economía sino también con
la gestión del gobierno nacional de
brasil durante la pandemia
estos son puntos que fragilizan al
discurso de evolucionar pero creyó que
su principal aniversario que es el
presidente lula también tiene problemas
en su imagen en su contra por la
cuestión de la corrupción de que estaba
en la cárcel entonces creo que la
campaña de bolsonaro va a explotar
muchísimo estos puntos intentar a atacar
la popularidad de lula revertir intentar
recuperar electores
apoyadores de bajos ingresos que hoy
están con lula por una cuestión de
memoria económica de cómo vivían mejor
10 o 12 o 15 años atrás hoy ya no viven
está ya no vive en la misma condición
sin embargo bolsonaro está trabajando
para intentar recuperar estos electores
y yo creo que puede tener
un grado de éxito en esta estrategia
claro es un escenario muy distinto hace
15 años había una explosión
internacional de commodities que le
facilitó mucho la economía durante esos
años de gobierno al presidente lula jugó
a su favor quiero preguntarle a dar la
palabra a johanna rápidamente wagner que
tiene a favor bolsonaro para mostrar de
estos años de gobierno que él pueda
sacar bajo la manga y decir en mi
gobierno hicimos esto y ha funcionado
porque hay varios medios que titulan que
el presidente dice que el país va muy
bien y que incluso está mejor a como él
lo recibió
si hay una recuperación aunque pequeña
del nivel de empleo en brasil pero
pequeña hay una alguna deflación una
caída de los precios por ejemplo de la
gasolina de los combustibles pero aún no
se sabe si por sonar va a tener tiempo
hasta la elección que estamos a pocas
semanas de la elección de primera vuelta
por lo menos va a tener tiempo de poder
disfrutar de esta mejora de los niveles
de la economía niveles de empleo baja de
los precios de los combustibles de la
gasolina etcétera
entonces creo yo que bolsonaro está
corriendo contra el tiempo para intentar
para intentar lograr este es estos
pequeños éxitos que lo pueden garantizar
algunos miles o millones de votos más
para su para su campaña y joana en el
reino unido- su perspectiva de cómo
llega el presidente-candidato jair
bolsonaro ahí damos algunos algunos
datos para terminar de armar este
rompecabezas
bueno como lo había mencionado
anteriormente con unos altos niveles de
inflación aunque hay una breve de
recuperación macroeconómica después de
la pandemia
también se encuentra como lo mencionó
wagner en una leve recuperación de los
índices de empleo pero a estos es una
precarización laboral
también está acompañada por un aumento
de los habitantes en situación de calle
las cifras son alarmantes y el 230 por
ciento se registra en el aumento de
habitantes de calles de sao paulo eso
indica que los índices de miseria están
creciendo y toda esa situación social
las movilizaciones la precariedad y la
pobreza es lo que está apoyando al alul
hay que lula tiene a su favor
también en términos de política exterior
un gobierno bastante polarizante que no
ha tenido un buen desempeño y que en
términos del cambio climático y el giro
a la izquierda que se está dando en
américa latina pues no están cuadrando
en ese ajedrez
de la muerte reciente de un periodista
inglés dos clips del garden en el
amazonas nos dice mucho sobre las
restricciones a la libertad de prensa a
los movimientos sociales
el giro a tendencias
restrictivas que no están promoviendo la
democracia sino que están siendo cada
vez más
autoritarias
joan a él le pregunta ahora por el otro
candidato el ex presidente lula da silva
que llega con un historial bastante
particular estuvo en la cárcel por casos
de corrupción por esta investigación
que llevó al caso de la vallado que
luego pasó a hacer
a nivel de latinoamérica
y llega allí después de un giro
inesperado en la justicia brasileña y se
perfila pues como uno de los dos
favoritos para llegar a la presidencia
balance del ex presidente lula para está
para esta contienda electoral
bueno evidentemente el candidato lula
también tiene sombras en su imagen como
bien lo mencionó el profesor bacnet y
pues son los escándalos de corrupción
asociados a la valla touring
inicialmente denominada así
esto pues no juega a favor de de lula y
pues inicialmente en medio una
polarización esperaríamos que la derecha
estuviera unida del lado bolsonaro pero
esto no está sucediendo
ya que lula está planteando una alianza
una coalición importante con un sector
neoliberal con un exalcalde
y ha reprimido protestas sociales
entonces la inconformidad de
de de la población brasilera se ve
reflejada no sólo en los sectores
críticos en los sectores que están
sufriendo la pobreza en la miseria pero
también en la derecha neoliberal que se
está apartando del modelo de gobierno de
personas
impactar su perspectiva de lula da silva
lula tiene un desafío son muchos
desafíos de verdad pero tiene un desafío
importante a mí me parece que está
logrando éxito que es intentar como
mencionaba a juana intentar de
involucrar no solamente en su campaña no
solamente y sectores de izquierdas
sectores progresistas pero también
sectores de los grandes empresarios de
la derecha democrática sectores
liberales este es un desafío a mí me
parece que está logrando construir una
alianza bastante interesante y muy
poderosa incluso su calidad para
vicepresidente es un ex aniversario es
un hombre conservador de derecha que fue
gobernador de la provincia del estado de
san pablo
pero lula tiene un otro desafío muy
importante y esto me parece tan
estratégico cuando el primero pero más
difícil que es como tú señalabas incluso
en la presentación de nuestro debate de
santiago que es conquistar los sectores
de bajos ingresos los sectores populares
que están vinculados a las iglesias
cristianas pero aquí es importante
señalar que no son católicos sino que
están en iglesias cristianas
evangelistas protestantes
neopentecostales que son muy
conservadoras en términos de costumbres
de temas de moralidad de temas sobre por
ejemplo el papel de la mujer en la
sociedad el papel de la familia
tradicional entonces ahí lugar tiene un
obstáculo muy muy
fuerte para intentar
para intentar superar y con esta gente
bolsonaro tiene una una proximidad un
acercamiento
muy muy fuerte y creo que ahí con este
electorado los cristianos evangelistas
bolsonaro se mantiene más o menos con
una buena parte de sus 35 por ciento de
intención de votos al una clave para
lula se presenta el desafío de intentar
conquistar esos electores que son en su
gran mayoría electores pobres electores
de los sectores populares pero que
paradojalmente con una paradoja no no no
están columna no están con una
plataforma
electoral de avance de los derechos
sociales son gente que aunque esté a
bajo el desempleo baja bajo la pobreza
su decisión de voto es también muy
influenciada por cuestiones morales a
donde evolucionar el trabajo me viene
wagner entonces podemos decir que esta
elección por lo menos esta primera
vuelta va a estar definida por los
sectores populares y en tiendas en la
división en ese sector popular entre las
clases menos favorecidas económicamente
que ya usted me corregirá si estoy
haciendo mal el análisis corresponde a
los grandes centros urbanos es decir el
río de janeiro y san pablo y
mayoritariamente el norte este del país
y estos bloques religiosos que también
representan un grueso de la población
ahí es donde van a estar los votos que
van a definir quién va a ser el
presidente o quién pasa esta segunda
vuelta
encima de clase empresarial o la clase
dirigente habitual de los estados un
poco más ricos en el sur del país como
lo puedes analizar
hay una división de más o menos hoy en
brasil hay una división de votos más o
menos como en eeuu entre republicanos y
demócratas en la región noreste de
brasil a donde está por ejemplo país y
pernambuco ceará ahí lula tiene un
liderazgo impresionante como una
proposición de tres o cuatro votos para
uno en relación a personar en términos
de las encuestas sin embargo en los
estados en las regiones de brasil a
donde está el agronegocio de exportación
el cultivo de soya de ganado ganadería
etcétera ha evolucionado tiene un
liderazgo entonces a mí me parece que
hay una compensación a donde lula lidera
y bolsonaro pierde
bolsonaro líder en otros estados los
estados de la frente del agronegocio y
dura pierde más o menos la misma
proporción entonces la decisión de esta
lección va a estar en las grandes
ciudades del sureste de brasil como tú
mencionas santiago río de janeiro sao
paulo belo horizonte grandes centros
urbanos del sureste de brasil a donde
hoy hoy las encuestas apuntan para una
situación de mucho equilibrio entre dos
candidatos entonces tau aunque lugares
de aire las encuestas hoy la dirección
está totalmente abierta no hay una
definición no se puede hacer una pulgada
hoy sobre la victoria de lula o no no
por eso he evitado hablar de encuestas
en la introducción del programa porque
todo puede cambiar de aquí hasta el 2 de
octubre joana interesante mirar lo que
está pasando en brasil
que es una realidad que tal vez es
transversal para los países de américa
latina lo vimos en colombia lo vimos en
chile también son sociedades
completamente polarizadas que se
enfrentan los electores a izquierda a
derecha a conservadores ya tal vez a
movimientos un poco más progresistas y
brasil llega con la parte con la
particularidad de llegar con las
amenazas de un posible fraude por parte
del presidente que también es candidato
que ha desacreditado el sistema de voto
que ya lo vamos a entrar a analizar
y llega con esta completa polarización y
también con muchas denuncias de
desinformación por parte de las redes
sociales y de los servicios de internet
de las personas que publican allí cosas
que los brasileños los han tomado como
verdades para esta campaña
si no es información allí juega un papel
fundamental
creo que este fenómeno de las técnicas
se está haciendo
ampliamente extendido en las sociedades
occidentales pero acá además de una
desacreditación de los órganos
electorales
también hubo insinuaciones de un golpe
de estado o la retórica golpista en el
discurso de corte de bolsonaro ha
seguido incrementando para mantener a
sus electores unidos
santiago muy importante lo convenciones
en términos del panorama latinoamericano
ya que
[Música]
en estas estas elecciones eran
fundamentales para definir el panorama
regional
ya
a excepción de argentina y uruguay
habría un giro radical a la izquierda
latinoamericana me gustaría matizar eso
diciendo que sean izquierdas variadas
que están llenas de coaliciones y que no
llegan siendo las izquierdas
tradicionales radicales como bolsonaro
en la denuncia de su discurso esto no es
una lucha del comunismo y el capitalismo
de tiempos de la guerra fría es una
izquierda mucho más diversa que le está
apostando a la inclusión de sectores
amplios como lo estamos viendo en
colombia también en brasil en chile
y que tiene un desafío porque en un
continente que ha venido de una
tradición dictatorial en el que después
en el siglo 20 todos los países de
américa la tiene estuvieron con
dictaduras a excepción de una dictadura
prolongada pues en colombia la
transición a la democracia es un proceso
largo y ese proceso
requiere que no conseguiremos lo que
algunos autores en la ciencia política
ha sido un autoritarismo competitivo
pero condiciones para que haya una
democracia plural en la que se respeten
los derechos sociales
interesante ese punto joana me quedo con
usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
estábamos tocando el tema de la
desinformación me llamó la atención esa
decisión del tribunal superior electoral
de brasil de ordenar en el canal estatal
brasileño tv brasil y también en algunos
canales y redes sociales en ese país a
retirar ese vídeo en donde el presidente
de ayer bolsonaro justamente ataca al
sistema de votación del país que fue el
sistema de votación que lo eligió a él
como presidente y lo tiene en el palacio
de planalto gracias a este sistema de
una urna electrónica es un sistema muy
particular el único en américa latina'
parte de esa desinformación viene de uno
de los candidatos como entiende uno que
se gestiona está esta campaña de
desinformación incluso bolsonaro ya dijo
que si él no ganaba la elección iba a
decir que había fraude iba a denunciarlo
y no iba a aceptar el resultado
bueno
el nombramiento reciente del director de
la autoridad electoral puede explicar un
poco está esta dinámica que está
explicando santiago
pero
también el hecho de que will solar esté
incitando a sus electores en las redes
sociales y en los medios masivos de
comunicación a apoyar esa de
desacreditación del mismo organismo
electoral que lo eligió pues hace que
ésta hace esta decisión del organismo
electoral sea legítima en tanto que está
tratando de
detener un mensaje de odio contra la
institución electoral tal vez en américa
latina' estos mensajes tienden a
normalizarse más pero en el mundo pues
democrático occidental en europa estos
mensajes son directamente borrados o
reprimidos porque incitan cuando de
vacío
paso ahora a preguntarle a wagner
justamente por este el sistema de
elecciones este voto electrónico muy
particular en brasil solamente países
como bélgica australia india y brasil-
tienen algo parecido que a cada
candidato se le asigna un código y esta
urna es capaz de capturar el dato que
suministra el elector y esto va a una
central dentro de esta máquina que luego
son contabilizados por en otra instancia
del conteo de los votos
en parte esto se hace por la magnitud de
la de las elecciones que toca llevar a
cabo por la cantidad de votantes que hay
y porque el voto es obligatorio
wagner pero que tanto tiene entonces
esta estrategia estas denuncias que hace
bolsonaro genera desconfianza entre el
electorado allí en las calles en el día
a día la gente comenta desconfía de este
sistema electrónico
yo creo que no que la mayoría de la
población brasileña no desconfía del
sistema electrónico a excepción de los
apoyadores de bolsonaro este discurso de
bolsonaro me me parece un poco similar
al discurso de don autrán cuando intentó
su reelección en la disputa contra joe
biden en eeuu es una especie de res con
una especie de vacuna para en caso de
derrota se poner inmediatamente como
como alguien que que fue víctima de una
injusticia y que aunque sea obligado a
aceptar los resultados y salir del poder
salir de la silla presidencial se pone
en el día siguiente como un opositor muy
radical al nuevo presidente que la
población venga a elegir
ahora mencionaba una cosa también muy
importante el poder de las farc news de
las de las noticias mentirosas que se
difunden por redes sociales esto ya fue
un elemento también determinante en la
elección de 2018 en brasil y sigue sigue
como como un elemento muy muy muy fuerte
en esta campaña de optique 2022
bolsonaro fue elegido por las urnas
electrónicas en 2018 pero es importante
señalar también recordar que bolsonaro
si no me equivoco fue diputado general
de brasil por siete o ocho
ocasiones y en todas fue elegido fue
elegido también por las urnas
electrónicas y jamás había contestado
las urnas la seguridad la transparencia
de las urnas electrónicas sus tres hijos
también fueran elegidos porque ya
empezaron sus propias carreras políticas
con este patrimonio político que su
padre tiene
en sus tres hijos también fueron
elegidos por las urnas electrónicas y
jamás habían contestado el mecanismo sin
embargo ahora están contestando y este
es un elemento de un elemento de
desestabilización
de esta campaña política de 2022 que
puede tener resultados consecuencias
postelectorales muy complicadas
wagner y el otro candidato luiz inácio
lula da silva no ha dicho absolutamente
nada en torno a este tema del sistema de
voto electrónico pero que han dicho las
autoridades precisamente para desmentir
estas acusaciones porque da mucha
tranquilidad y hay que hacer énfasis en
este tema porque ese énfasis es
importante es decir que el candidato
está poniendo en duda el sistema
electoral en sí entonces por eso estoy
haciendo énfasis y profundizando en este
tema pro que dicen las autoridades a
raíz de estas elecciones del 2008 donde
hubo desinformación donde hubo críticas
y éstas del puesto que se tienen lugar
en el 2022
las autoridades de la justicia electoral
del órgano que ya que hay en brasil que
gestiona las elecciones no solamente
discursos sobre la seguridad la
transparencia la eficiencia de las urnas
sino que hacen pruebas técnica y
técnicas tecnológicas todo el tiempo
para poder para poder
envasar para poder
reforzar
la posición de que el sistema funciona
funciona muy bien y está funcionando
hace muchos años en brasil e incluso
ahora ahora no pero hace algunos meses
ya las fuerzas armadas también están
trabajando junto a la justicia electoral
para hacer estas pruebas sobre la
seguridad sobre la fide y dignidad sobre
la transparencia del proceso electoral
brasileño a través de las urnas
electrónicas y no hay ninguna evidencia
de que se pueda frau dar este sistema
entonces
es mucho más que un discurso hay
efectivamente
pruebas tecnológicas de que el sistema
funciona y que es seguro
joana hemos hablado en este programa
sobre las diferentes dificultades y
temas que a simple vista uno nota en
esta realidad política y social en
brasil pero cualquier de usted que van a
hacer entonces esos temas sobre los que
giren las campañas de estos dos
candidatos si bien aclarando que la
campaña apenas está comenzando esta
disputa apenas está comenzando veíamos
casos chile tema central fue la
renovación de la constitución en
colombia fue el cambio necesario y la
unidad del país por encima de temas como
la pobreza o un pacto de paz con alguna
de las guerrillas en brasil- cuáles
serían esos ese eje central de una
campaña
bueno pues creo que hay varios temas
creo que
dadas las características de los
candidatos y el nivel de polarización
entre una ultra derecha y una izquierda
diversa el tema de la pobreza el
crecimiento y el desempeño
macroeconómico la inflación el precio de
los combustibles va a ser determinante
de la misma manera
[Música]
un tema fundamental van a ser las
políticas sociales ligadas a este tema
del desempeño macroeconómico en general
desde el punto de vista internacional
tal vez no de la agenda interna o la
política ambiental de cara a las
transformaciones que se están dando y
que otros presidentes de la izquierda ya
han anunciado como borikén chile y petro
en colombia sobre justicia ambiental y
cambio climático como lo hacemos para
crear alianzas regionales que le apunten
a una una transformación energética
regional giovanna y ese punto
medioambiental puede ser otro
otra plataforma para volver a llevar a
brasil a ese liderazgo regional que ha
venido perdiendo terreno a lo largo de
los últimos años como lo vio usted sí
claro en potencia regional brasil ya se
ha
establecido durante los últimos años en
la geopolítica latinoamericana como una
potencia regional pero esto pues claro
que se ha transformado durante la
pandemia pero
muy claramente con las políticas
ambientales que bolsonaro ha impulsado
los dos resultados de las elecciones
serían muy importantes porque si ganara
bolsonaro que en este momento de acuerdo
a los a los pronósticos de las encuestas
no parece tan probable tendría la región
en contra para establecer alianzas
regionales y en el caso de brasil si en
el caso de que lula pudiera ganar las
elecciones no lo sabemos aún con certeza
parece que el panorama es más favorable
para restablecer esa potter esa posición
de potencia regional de brasil wagner no
puedo dejar de preguntarle por las otras
selecciones que están también en juego
son importantes la cámara de
representantes- renueva parte de sus
escaños y también en parte o la
totalidad de la cámara y parte del
senado es lo que van a elegir los
brasileños como están las cargas
electorales allí
hay una tendencia hay pocas encuestas
para la cámara y para el senado sin
embargo hay una tendencia de que la
izquierda o las izquierdas diversas como
señalaba juana pueden aumentar su
participación en el congreso brasileño
en el congreso de las leyes importantes
señalar que no tiene la cara del pueblo
brasileño si tú vas a brasilia y entras
al plenario de la cámara de los
diputados desde el senado de la
república casi todos los representantes
son hombres de 50 a 60 años de edad o
más blancos ricos representantes del
gobierno lobbies muy poderosos hizo nada
tiene que ver con el pueblo el pueblo
brasileño que que es mucho más diverso
entonces creo que el paisaje humano de
la cámara de diputados del senado
brasileño va a cambiar en esta elección
porque sectores de la juventud de los
movimientos negros de los movimientos
feministas de los movimientos de las
gentes
podemos indígenas están muy muy muy
movilizados para elegir sus
representantes sin embargo los sectores
conservadores de brasil muchos
involucrados con las iglesias
evangelistas o con grupos empresariales
también están muy movilizados para
mantener sus posiciones de poder dentro
del relativo de brasil me gustaría no
solamente de señalar una cosa más que
que mencionaba peruana estos temas
económicos sin duda está en el centro de
la campaña electoral y brasil este año
pero a mí me parece que como bolsonaro
no tiene mucho para presentar en
términos de logros económicos estos son
temas mucho más de la izquierda y de
lula bolsonaro va a hablar muchísimo de
corrupción y corrupción del del partido
de los trabajadores de lula de silva y
también de los temas de inmoralidad de
costumbres de la familia tradicional
etcétera a mí me parece que este son los
grandes temas de esta elección pues a
johanna de wagner les agradezco por
haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 esta carrera
presidencial apenas está comenzando
sabremos el 2
y quiénes son los que pasarán a esa
segunda vuelta electoral les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales y en sintonía de
france 24
[Música]